that's amazing dude you know how it
takes a four months off of my knee and I
broke two toes and but I still suck I
don't really have the time to go four
times a week right now if I could go
four times a week I'd get really good
really fast you know but I just don't
and I don't think I could recover that
much for days of Jiu-Jitsu you know but
have you seen it improve other parts of
your life even if you're not absolutely
I've done a lot of every time I go to
Jiu-Jitsu and I walk out I feel really
good about myself because it's the
hardest thing I'll do I've said it a
thousand times so it changes my day and
and I'll tell you what let's say I have
Jiu-Jitsu I have an opportunity to go to
Jiu-Jitsu and I can't go because I have
an audition I don't feel bad but if I
don't go because I don't go I feel bad
like if I have an opportunity to go and
I don't go I'm like ah I don't feel like
going today I feel bad about myself but
as soon as I go to Jiu-Jitsu and I walk
out of there I'm a different person I'm
a different person on stage I'm a
different animal when I'm writing
I'm a different animal towards my wife
towards the baby I can feel it it does
it calms me down a little bit I enjoy it
even though I'm not good at it it's
amazing I enjoy I enjoy just getting
thrown on my back and trying to get out
of the [__] situation and thinking
and you know if you run out of breath
you just tap out and that's it that's it
you know I learned these little
exercises so I don't have anxiety no
more and I panic if you have fear fear
is in your breath and you can control
the fear through your breath okay so uh
there's these exercises I do now and
it's helped me [__] dramatically man
yeah it I mean just the fact of sticking
with
it it's all about showing up you know I
see it I see it in comedy I see it in
people's actions you know people start
things then they just fall off to the
side uh and even if you can't go eight
times a week you know you do it one time
that's why I tell you all the time when
I quiet go you do a push-up today I
always do a push-up P up every [__]
morning at one point I can't do a
push-up but I try to do two three four
and eventually I can get up to [__]
20 again you know at 300 lb you lose a
[__] 100 PB you're [__] tremendous
you could do 2,000 push-ups so it all
starts with one and just keep showing up
man I see it with comedy I see how it
affected you know I got a weird way of
thinking when it comes to Comedy and I
don't share My Views people always say
me why don't you to to people in comedy
why don't you because I have to have a
talk with them before I would meet them
like I would have to have like that talk
that Carter Andre Carter's father said
to him are you sure are you sure because
this is what's expected of you when you
make the jump into comedy and if you
don't jump into it that way it's not
going to pan out for you it might take
you a little longer you might get to
this the process but this is how it
needs to be attacked and a lot of people
when I talk to them about that type of
stuff they look at me [__] weird like
did you days off don't you have a social
life it depends on what you want you got
to look at your social life and go huh
what time is the party from oh till
three Lee I'm going to go do a spot
first yeah but they cut the cake at 9:15
that's great I'm 50 years old who gives
a [__] about your cake you know I got to
go do a spot first and then you you you
you make uh deals with yourself you know
but sometimes for me the spot overruled
everything it it overruled everything no
matter what you had going on or somebody
else going on or what I wanted to do if
I had a a way to do standup comedy that
night it was going to
overrule all this [__] I had [__]
going on that somebody else had going on
a lot of people used to get [__]
pissed off at me they still do they
still do you know Eddie Bravo did two
tournaments I didn't show up to either
one of them you know how bad I feel so
not I didn't book that week I'm
definitely going to ebi it's March 22nd
I think uh and downtown yeah yeah so I'm
going to stay in town for that but it's
uh we talk about it a lot about people's
work ethics and it's not just in
LA but it's um even I I still struggle
with it more than I did even a year ago
but it's hard because you you think
you're supposed to do all these things
like you have we say Friday night is
Dick night but if you had a gig or or if
there was a podcast you'd have to work
it's not most people think they need
Friday and Saturday it's still dick
night it's always dick night it's always
dick night on Friday night when you get
home you just give Mama stabing right
but
uh growing up I don't know I always felt
that you there was this pressure on you
that you had to go out on Friday and
Saturday nights right and in high school
I took that away I used to just not go
out on a Friday night just to see how it
would feel just to see what and it was
like I would wake up the next morning
and make a call and see what I missed
and I would get the report oh you missed
this guy he threw a bottle at this guy
we went to this bar we went to this
place and ate and you know what but I
realized I didn't miss a [__] thing
right when you're young and you're
trying to budget you can't go out seven
nights a week sometimes so I would go
out three you know when I went out I did
Coke there was pills there was cars
there was clubs it wasn't you know $10
to go out right you drop 200 you know in
those days now you Dro 400 I'm just
saying 200 kid when you're just the
street you do three nights a week that's
$600 [__] dollars that's 2400 a month
and just going out I was doing that you
know MH but still I was still budgeting
like going what I'll go out on Sunday
and get [__] up I'll go out on
Thursday and get [__] up maybe
Saturday get [__] up you know so I was
always uh and people think they're
entitled to it like if you told somebody
oh you have to work Friday night a lot
of people say oh I I I have to go out
Friday night the what made me think
about it was it's knowing so much in
Boston right now that the college I went
to I had to cancel out classes and
they're they're scheduling remake
classes on the weekends for a little bit
just to catch up and there there some
kids are signing a petition not to do
classes on weekends and I'm just like
and when I was a in college I probably
would have thought the same way but just
looking at it now it's I've had to work
so many weekends like it really doesn't
like just because you don't want to take
a class because you usually go out
Saturday night doesn't it doesn't mean
anything I had a you know I think if I
wouldn't have lost my parents I think
that I would have watched more Sports on
Sunday but because I lost my mom and I
had a different mindset and sometimes I
had a sacrifice that's one of the
sacrifices you know to some people I
don't put it down I just don't
understand it but they don't understand
my way of life so that's what makes life
interesting I don't understand how if
you have an opportunity to make money on
a Friday
night
uh doing something that you love that's
the other thing we got to discuss doing
something that you enjoy doing let's say
you had a work let's say your boss came
to he goes you got to work Friday and
Saturday and you said [__] it how about
I just work Saturday and Friday not I
work you know whatever pick one that I
could see when you're 2022 that's a hard
you know when you're [__] 20 your
friends are out here you are working in
a fast food [__] restaurant to pay
you know your parents will pay for
tuition but you got to pay for room and
whatever the [__] your food and your
books and your meals they make you
pretty good deal you got to come up with
300 so you get a job at Taco Bell you
make 600 you have 300 for you to party
with and 300 for you to pay for you you
know to justify your [__] existence
you know a lot of those jobs when you're
in college are Friday [__] Saturday
nights you're either bartending you're
working a [__] door so you sacrific
that already I would you know I wouldn't
when I was in high school when I quit
high school that September that was that
August for like two months I had a job
that you worked Friday nights and when
they told me what I was going to make
and what the job was and the benefits I
didn't even think about it I still got
out at like 10:00 if I wanted to I still
had the whole [__] night but some
people wow how the [__] are you doing my
friend Glenn who is still at UPS he
[__] gave up Fridays and Saturdays in
high school Friday nights because he had
that job 11: to 2 oh okay where you go
11:00 and you load trucks still [__]
2:30 a.m. do that when you're in high
school and that eliminates that whole
[__] lifestyle but he had to do it
for a reason there was a need right
there was a need there was a need for
that money you know so I don't know
people you could say it's a Jew thing
but I've had a job since I was 15 and I
I can't tell you how many Fourth of July
I worked how many holidays how many my
birthdays so it's just it's Sur just
another [__] day guy right and I
understand I understand I sympathize
some people like the party some people
like to jump up and down and [__]
giggle and go out and whatever I liked
all that [__] too but if it's between
[__] eating and you know what are you
going to do Mo off your [__] friends
right you have to make some sort of a
living you have to do something you know
uh whatever it may be I just eliminated
Fridays and Saturdays from my life and
in this point now I'm a stand up I work
on Fridays and Saturdays last week it
was pissing me off what because
everybody kept coming and going so
you're not going to watch to fight like
it was the end of the world you know
what man sometime again if it's between
a fight and me doing comedy
I [__] do comedy I don't give a [__]
if it's a $15 spot or I'm working a
weekend at one of my favorite [__]
clubs if they call me from The Comedy
Store on a Saturday and they go hey you
have a spot at
10:45 and that's when the fight starts
that so be it I'm one of those guys and
I've always been like that again because
there was a need right I was either a
junkie I needed the money I you know you
can't focus on it I love sports I grew
up on Sports I don't ever want anybody
to think that I'm misin ing myself when
I say I only watch two plays at the
Super Bowl I mean at you know when I was
a kid somebody told me you gamble
basketball yeah just watch the last two
minutes that's all that matters if you
gamble basketball because it it's all
the way to the end you never know if a
guy just gets foul he makes three three
[__] three three three free throws it
doesn't affect the game it affects the
point spread you get killed up the ass
right you know they win by seven instead
of 10 and you got a seven and a half you
get caught by that [__] hook
basketball yeah that sucks they're
always great at I heard they only made
like 3 and a half million on the Super
Bowl who did the Vegas book uh veggas
casinos is that what you heard yeah good
you bought that [__] line all these
junkies three and a half million they
made money that's their biggest day of
the year what about the elicit [__]
see listen let's say let's pretend
you're
uh I don't know I don't know some
[__] Rich celebrity all right who's
in the public guy okay and you're a
gambling [__] degenerate you got two
options all right you could get your
best high school friend who's also
probably degenerate from high school
that you grew up with and you get him to
put bets in for you in
Vegas doesn't take two and two together
when you're a [__] [__] and you're
driving to Mercedes into Vegas and bling
75,000 that this is not for you right
right people going to say oh he's doing
it for Joey Diaz or he's doing it for
Joe Rogan or he's doing it for Ari or
Duncan what [__] it is so after a while
when you're a gambling junkie what what
the [__] do you do so you have other
outlets and you have these big time
bookies that are across the country that
are banks they'll take 40 $50,000 from
me those still exist yeah they [__]
still exist what they go away I thought
it would have just all gone to websites
now no no no no [__] those way would you
trust somebody with $50,000 on a [__]
website I don't know if I trust trust a
bookie a book listen if you got a bookie
if you come to me and you go listen Joey
I like to [__] gamble but I want to
bet 10,000 a game I don't want no
[__] drama and I want to make sure
I'm paid every week I'll make a few
phone calls and I'll find a specific
bookie that'll take 10,000 a game you
probably have to warant him the money
the first 10 times to put the game to
build trust so before you build the game
you got to Y them 10 GS you know but
that's that they're out there they'll
take 10,000 you know who the [__] are
they if you came to me right now and
said I want to put 10,000 how do you
know how I know you're [__] good for
it right so I come with a reputation you
want to bet
10,000 you also want it to be discreet
you're Brad Pit you don't ever want me
to [__] say nothing you know so
you're also looking for somebody who's
very discreet you're looking for all
these things Le so the other way to do
it is to bet with books in Ohio
Cleveland you know uh Cleveland Ohio
Youngstown you know maybe you know big
Bank in [__] Miami a big Bank in
Louisiana they got a couple big banks in
Louisiana and you could call them up and
say I need I'm putting $250,000 down I
don't want nobody to [__] know this
[__] wow I didn't even know that world
still those people what you think you're
going to go to if if let's say you got a
[__] wife and you got kids and you
think you're going to call Vegas and put
$250,000 down it gets taxed everybody
knows your [__] business you know
what do you think I don't know I'm just
saying I'm just saying if you don't if
you want to be discreet
how do you I mean maybe it's just cuz I
was never in that at all but even with
like drug dealers now bookies how did
you know I would never know where to go
to start to find one you go to a bookie
but yeah they say a bookie goes I can't
take that type but they don't have a a
sign above a window but they know
they're a bookie they know somebody who
does take that action okay if I want to
find the bookie take me 10 minutes right
now really 10 minutes I just get on the
phone and make three calls in an hour
somebody will call me back and then
we'll take it from there there and then
I call him up and I all right what do
you want to take an action well I don't
really know you where do you live I live
in North Hollywood okay I'll meet you
before the games and give you a thousand
a game about six or seven times I bet we
start betting everything's cool after
that I call him up and I go listen I
want to bet 2500 a game let me call my
guy see if he'll take that from me calls
his guy no worries boom we go back for a
few months I call him up one day they go
listen why are we [__] around I want
to put 20 G's on this [__] game he's
going tell me he's not taking it his guy
is not going to take it but they know a
guy and for 10% or 5% they'll call it
bet [__] so I I I is it is it the same
like lines remember for me to take a
$10,000 bet I got to have 10,000 on the
other side to create a Utopia right I'm
just not going to take a $10,000 bet
from you just to take it from you I got
to have a $10,000 bet on the other side
so if whatever happens I get The
Vig okay that's how I make my money I
get The Vig so when you put a $10,000
bet if you lose you're paying me
11,000 oh W I'm paying Tom sagur 10,000
I'm keeping that th000 off the top
that's how a bookie makes a living he's
not just going to take your $10,000 bet
without a backing over here oh okay okay
so he takes 10,000 from you I got to
make sure I got 10 on the other side I
don't lose I'm going to so let's say at
the end of the night I got
$38,000 for uh New England and I got
31 for uh Seattle Seattle I'm a cocky
guy I'll keep 33 and I'll call five into
a buddy of mine in Miami oh okay all
right let's do
it what's up my brother how you doing
you know me dog over here [__]
schooling Le on the lessons of
bookmaking explaining a Utopia to him I
was explaining to him like if you want
call like if you called me George and
said Joey I know you're a long time I
really like George St Pierre I want to
put 10 G's on him I would say well go to
the sports book you know Joey I work
right there I don't want people to know
my business you know okay I call a guy
right and he says yeah he'll take the
bet that guy just doesn't take the BET
George he has to have somebody else on
the other side betting 10,000 on C
Seattle because no matter what happens
if if Lee loses the 10 he gives me the
10 I pass it right to you Lee's giving
me
1100 he's giving me 11,000 exactly so
yeah that that 10% called the Vigor The
Vig so that Vig is how I make my living
the tries to get even action on both
sides that way he can always take home
the Vigor not B it's not always GNA work
that way sometimes it's just going to be
heavy on one side and of course they
cross their fingers and hope that that
side loses but for the most part a
perfect day for the bookie is a million
on the Patriots and a million on the
Seahawks they'll keep their 100,000 and
then knock off all those parlays and
teasers and all them other exotic FS how
long the star single banners is going to
go you know is it going to be heads or
tails you know is Tom Brady gonna Bang
three chicks or four chicks after the
game that kind of stuff that's what they
they clean up
on what's up my brother
George not much man one of the most
hanging out here one of the most
interesting weeks in MMA the show as
always one of the most interesting weeks
in MMA and one of the most saddest weeks
in MMA as far as I'm concerned couple of
weeks as soon as I uh read that
yesterday I called you
because I didn't know what the [__] to
think you know and both of them both of
them fail a [__] drug test I mean and
then Jon Jones a few weeks ago but as
far as this both of these [__]
fail a drug test I could see one guy or
you know but the guys that are fighting
each other this is uh it's like a
[__] black eye you know but is the
Nick Diaz one really who didn't expect
Nick Diaz to test positive for
that you know what do you think George I
expected it I expected I mean I know I
shouldn't say not that I you know what
honestly MMA has so many interesting
characters and 50 shows nowadays per
year just in the UFC alone we cover Bel
all World Series I forget about [__] all
right so how' you remind hey Nick Diaz
he uh you know loves to smoke weed you
he go pop then I would have said
probably you know with a smirk but
honestly [__] saw a great fight on
Saturday that that I enjoyed that I
hated I I had mixed emotions about it
you know it was just great happy to see
both guys back in the Octagon after such
a long time uh at the end of the fight I
just thought wow I didn't expect that I
honestly thought Anderson was too big
fast strong for Nick Diaz regarded of
the layoffs Nick Diaz uh he was a gamer
man he went out there he fought he got
an answer face
and so at the end of the fight I thought
okay cool you know I wasn't expecting
any of that completely blindsided by the
Anderson Sila positive test the Nick
Diaz once I heard it I thought well [__]
what was I thinking of course he kind of
always does that his third time in
Nevada where's the shocker there but
Anderson Silva that took the wind out of
me I just don't and it's funny because I
called uh Ed Suarez early in the day
just to talk to him just to say hello
out the blue that morning I got up and I
go you know I haven't talked to Ed
Sinister since the fight I meant to call
him before the
fight and I left a message I don't want
him to think that I was calling him to
ask him stupid [__] questions now now
I feel bad but uh I never expected uh
and Hey listen you got to do what you
got to do it's a tough sport to train
for it's uh five six days three or four
different disciplines strength and
conditioning you know uh who knows what
goes on I don't I don't know how the
break down I what what gets you stronger
I don't know you know uh my heart goes
out to him my heart goes out to Nick
Diaz he is in my opinion this is the
this is not the pot calling the kettle
black he's [__]
crazy he's just [__]
crazy like we are definitely related
somewhere along the line our Bloodlines
are definitely def how old is he right
now i' put him around
32 I that's how what I was at 32 he's 31
he turns 32 in are you [__] kidding
me they giv that lunatic a half a
million dollars a fight he his rent is
8800 a month he has a bicycle you know
he doesn't go out he doesn't really I
don't think he drinks he smokes pot and
he throws those [__] n Chucks around
and he goes to Jiu-Jitsu and he swims
and he runs how much weed will $500,000
last him for they give him pounds of
weed at that [__] store up there in
Stockton they give
yeah yet somehow he doesn't manage the
money right because he's always
complaining about being broke either
that or he's trolling him I know he has
a strict diet but when he goes out
everything's organic and you know that
thing can add up a little bit here and
there but still you're right man that's
500k plus his
endorsements uh you know it's going to
last them a long time well this time
it's gonna have to last them a long time
because this is his third offense so the
first one's about nine months and then
after that
they uh you know they listen to what you
got to say and go from there but man
um I don't know what the I don't know
what the UFC is gonna do the UFC's got
to start cleaning things up and they're
gonna have to make examples out of
someone and who knows man maybe it'll be
this cat this cat s tickets though he
has does sell tickets he's a character
he comes to fight I don't know I I I I
to speculate would be foolish on my part
because I know I'm going to be way off
and I'm in the industry and I'm ashamed
almost say that but honestly I can't
[__] figure out DOA which resides
about five miles away from our studio
here in in Las Vegas can't figure them
guys out I can't figure the athletes in
our sport out it's a confusing time to
cover the sport and to be an MMA fan
which I still am I may cover the sport
and talk to these Fighters every day but
I'm a fan and as a fan right now I'm
just a little I'm a little sad and
disappointed but you know what this is
an
ongoing uh soap opera I always call it
General hospital it's not going to end
the Sport's going to be around for a
long time it's just general hospital and
this is just LC and law [__] 30 years
ago doing whatever um you know and uh
tomorrow there'll be some more
controversies and we're all going to
forget about this one the happiest guy
on Earth has to be Jon Jones pressure is
off
him well you know I hope Jon Jones
recovers I hope all that goes well this
to me is just I mean they had a disaster
year last year with injuries and it
opened up the [__] year they just
lost three more [__] guys they just
lost Weidman they lost Anderson Silva
off the roster they lost Nick Diaz you
know jackar Ray got hurt uh yoel Romero
got hurt which like I told you the other
day in my opinion was the best fight of
the [__] year and it was the best
fight of that [__] card in LA to be
honest with you uh you know the the bad
luck continues for the
UFC uh right immediately last night I
sat there at one point and I wrote UFC
you know uh you know Karma whatever the
[__] I wrote on Twitter and I saw a
couple Fighters retweet it and a couple
MMA people retweeted and I could just
imagine you know I'm going to get that
call from somebody but in my world it's
like do you havec was fun the UFC was
fun to watch there was something about
it and all of a sudden it became
something else too
quickly and I think they're moving a
little too quick you know uh I don't
know what it is I'm not I have nothing
nothing nothing against Conor McGregor
but I don't like the how this whole
situation has been handled to get the
truth out there that's the truth I'm not
going to lie to anybody I don't like how
the Situation's been handle in what way
from A to Z I just do not like it I I
see what it
is I see what it is and it breaks my
[__]
heart that's it well can you can you
expand on that a little bit though what
what do you mean like they like they um
you don't like the way he has opened his
mouth and gotten opportunities as
opposed to other people that used to
maybe have to to get to the position I
think this whole thing started with
ch I think this whole thing started with
ch son I think that uh when he was
talking stuff about Anderson
Silva uh and going a little deeper than
what should have been and calling the
noera brothers names and stuff like that
I think right there Dana White should
have stopped that it it became something
else to me and his is a guy that I love
and respect but he was talking too much
he wasn't really covering the spread he
was not covering the [__] spread as
as a UFC fighter he was talking he was
selling tickets but it was like a fad
diet and then look what happened boom he
[__] test for peeds again you know
and he's gone and he created this whole
[__] bad taste mouth so now you get
this [__] bad taste in your mouth and
now you have uh Conor McGregor who's a
great fighter he's exciting he's got
Ireland behind him he fills stadiums you
know what there's not a person in a
[__] world that if I took him in in
in a room and and quizzed him said they
wanted to see him against Dennis
SAA you've been saying that for a while
it pissed me off the fight that I wanted
to see right then there was only one
fight he gets the winner of Cubs Swanson
Frankie Edgar and the winner of that
fight got Jose Aldo that's me as a fan
that's me as a fan that was the right
move right there when they put him up
and okay Dennis C was tough and he
destroyed Dennis cver in a in a
tremendous fashion and all this [__] I
still have a bad taste in my mouth and I
know Conor McGregor's working hard on
his Jiu-Jitsu I know that he's doing a
tournament in April and it's like that
buying the kid
time and I get it I get it but I look at
the gates and I look at the
pay-per-views and they just raised the
price and the pay-per-views so you're
holding out on one thing even though
you're making money you're making money
across the board but if this kid wins
this fight you're fighting in an arena
so this whole thing has been sold
because this kid's fighting an arena I
don't like the pictures of him drinking
out of a [__] coconut at a I don't
like him talking about how he's not even
in the fighter Hotel he's across the
street and the Fati is sweet I didn't
like that they're all fighters what does
Frankie Eder feel like at home when he
sees that and hears that what does GSP
feel like they made Millions for the
organization they're walking around the
[__] MGM in the morning and so is
[__] Frankie Eder you know this kid's
at the fatri S and making the fighters
feel bad about it I saw the interview
with Chad Mendes when he told him he was
going to have his ball sack on his face
it's just becoming something
else and if for some people too much
post to pro wrestling you
know like story lines the outcomes or
well not the storyline it's not the
storyline there's nothing fake about
getting KNE to the [__] head and
getting body slammed and getting uh arm
barred and [__] I just don't like the
path they're
taken that was it that's my whole fight
right there I wanted to see Frankie
edger against Conor McGregor that's it I
didn't like when Conor McGregor jumped
the fence and went after him and this
and D his bodyguard was right there
waiting for him you know and he held him
I just didn't like all this it's going
it's it's disrespectful all over again
it's what we learned with ch son and all
over again I'm not saying that this
kid's G to get popped for steroids I'm
not saying these things again I'm not
saying nothing negative about Conor
McGregor I'm just letting you guys see
the situation that I see so all right so
so let me ask you something here going
back to Anderson Sila you guys think
he's
done uh I didn't see the whole fight I'm
not going to lie to you but the mood I
got from
people was uh that he was done
or that's it we want him to go out like
this that's it you prove your point your
leg
healed come back beat
somebody get a Payday say goodbye n yet
you know go back to Brazil spend your
[__] McDonald
money open up a school do lectures
whatever the [__] you want to do but to
go out this way we're never going to see
him again they're going to suspend him
for six to nine months he's pretty much
done you know I was 5050 I thought
before the before I heard about the the
uh you know the
Peds I thought okay you know maybe he's
going to go off right here and blaz the
g bo he's talking about his family while
come home but right here he's gonna get
an automatic nine months he's already
pushing 40 and you know even though he's
come out and put out a statement that he
says he's never put anything illegal
into his body it's I mean come on man
they they don't they they don't uh mess
these tests up I me they have before but
[__] that man no way I I I just it's
going to be tough for him to prove his
innocence well you know I don't tamper
he's saying that they they may have
tampered with it or you know uh you know
the procedures he's going to find
loopholes in the procedures of the tth
chel sunen did an NV today he said man
if he did it just come
clean uh you know I've seen this with
Bobby Bond excuse me Barry Bond Roger
Clemens Lance arm
strong you know I don't know man it
sucks you made a mistake is how I look
at it now the question is do I go back
and and do I believe that he did this
the whole time CU at 32 years old is
when he got into the
UFC a lot of guys are on their way out
at 32 and at 32 he gets in the UFC and
starts lighting pools up so it wouldn't
be that far-fetched to think that he
could have done all this his career you
know but he passed every single test so
we got to believe that he didn't and in
this instance he did and maybe it was
with TR coming off the broken leg he
needed something to recover was [__]
with him mentally who knows he slipped
up but I guess that's the next thing
we're going to have to try and figure
out and see you'll see how forth coming
he
is the the thing I don't understand is
is the argument against using steroids
especially in fighting is that it would
give them an unfair advantage and they
be able to beat people up more than just
a a normal person would but then we
don't hear about this until after the
fight already happened so he the danger
would have already happened like why why
don't the results come out before the
fight yeah million dollar question right
there well both for him and Jones say
there's no way that they known you know
stop stop the fight from happening
because too much money at stake oh
they're even pulling the finger saying
that the that the commission may have
known of course the commission makes
keep some payday out of it as well but
you know um tell you well man we got
some good reporters in the sport
especially at junkie and they're going
to try and figure that out and see what
happened there uh because January 9th
you test and then you don't get the
results for three weeks later that
what's the point of the random test you
know you're supposed to pop these guys
but they don't go out there and and
perform you know uh enhanced and that
that's exactly what didn't happen on
Saturday night whole thing with Nick
Diaz again not shocked one bit that pot
that he may have smoked three uh three
weeks ago or whatever did nothing to
enhance his to flance that's the most
ridiculous thing out there hopefully
they change that going forward but the
thing with uh with Anderson
Sila I was Bot Man they need to they
need to get those results a lot quicker
than they
have understand George you want to clean
up the sport start the random testing
right now pick 100 of your athletes out
of the 500 uh you know that roster of
500 that they have pick a 100 names and
get them all tested within the next week
and let's just see how dirty that
organization is as a whole send the
message to everyone that's training you
know and and it's going to cost you some
money but you know what put the pedal to
the medal and do that for the next six
months a year two years do what you got
to do but you will not tolerate any type
of uh of cheating out there you know and
because it's terrible guys black cloud
over the
sport now this is what I understand in
1987 I got I got arrested and I got in
trouble in
1988 I got locked up I went to prison
and when I came out
89 90 I was in a halfway house if you
pissed on a Monday in 1990 at a halfway
house who has State funds which has no
money they I would always look at the
boxes when they tested me and that's how
I knew so let's say I had six tests a
month they would test me for four of
them were just for cocaine but for six
for two of the four for two of the six
so four of them will be for cocaine and
two of them will be for
everything like when I when went to
court with my
ex-wife my my ex-wife was pissed because
she kept saying I was smoking
dope right even though she was stealing
dope from me when she dropped the kid
off here's the beauty of
it she made she paid for urine test that
I had to take my attorney talked the
company and just tested me for blow not
for THC so the whole time they would get
the report they would say I was clean
for blow and other things but they
weren't testing me for
THC my point is the tests were coming
back in two [__] days that's what I
was going to ask you why are these
[__]
test coming back three weeks later the
UFC has money these people have test
when you get a job in Vegas they pull a
strand of hair out of your head and they
tell you everything you [__] did
every dick you suck every [__] with a
yeast infection you suck to the last
year did you know that George you do
know that you got a job as a [__]
valet at the MGM Grand right there what
before you could say I'll be back they
go B they take a [__] strand right
out of your head and they come back and
they go on November 28 you had 16
martinis and you took three of your
mother sleeping pills that's how good
the [__] test are that's how good the
[__] tests are all right that's one
thing number two let's talk about Jon
Jones I love Jon Jones I don't give a
[__] what happened I don't give a [__]
about the blow listen he's 26 years old
all right the same with Nick Diaz
they're 3 [__] one year you know what
I was doing when I was 31 do you have
any [__] idea
George no I was [__] acting just like
Nick Diaz even crazier you know here's
this kid who when did Jon Jones piss in
a bottle December 4th or something ath
December 4th December what happened was
I I'll CH in on that other thing we were
saying so Anderson Silva and Nick Diaz
that random testing that they had called
the water testing that one blood okay
it's random and they know that
throughout the camp there's probably a
good chance they're going to come
because the UFC been doing that for
about a year now and that one's blood
that's the one where it has to go
through a procedure and then they go to
I think there's one of the agencies is
in Salt Lake City the other one's in La
it takes a while man it's got to be
faster than what it is but that's what
happened the one they do after the fight
where they found out about the uh
marijuana metabolites that one's your
that one they can get back CH J quickly
within 24 48 hours so that's why we got
the result on Nick Diaz right away but
that but it also explains why the Jon
Jones one took about two three weeks uh
and and the Anderson Silva one took up
up two three weeks the difference was
with Anderson Silva the commission
stating that they didn't know until
yesterday that with H Jon Jones they
knew about a week before the fight the
difference was they weren't supposed to
test for Coke um and W World anti-doping
agency says that uh
cocaine when it's out of competition
meaning I guess within 12 hours of the
event they shouldn't be testing for that
so it's kind of like loophole stuff you
know but it doesn't make any sense at
all uh that that's why the UFC was able
to find him because it was a protoc
conduct policy thing and that's why they
had to come down on them uh and they did
find them but that's why they couldn't
stop the fight from happening because
out of competition and that's not
against water
ulations but why did they let him fight
that because he didn't do he technically
didn't do anything illegal it didn't but
it didn't even come out like Why didn't
it come out a week before the [__]
like I don't know there's something
there that's not right you and I both
know that I don't know about [__] I
don't know about [__] water W Daniel
Cormier and said hey look this this
happened you know it's up to you whether
you want to take a fight but I believe I
think Dar come's already stated he would
have taken the fight
regardless um but that that's basically
what it is is um it was out of
competition therefore like let's say
they found the cocaine metabolites after
the fight with the urine test like the
way they talk MC Diaz and you probably
have a no contest but because it's
happened out of competition there was
nothing they could do so what do you
mean so after the after the [__]
weigh in I go back to my room and I
snort [__] three lines of coke so the
next night when I fight after the fight
I come up positive and that means I did
the cocaine in
competition so you telling 12 hours it
would be a no cont it would be a no
contest and um technically what you said
would probably be out of competition
because they say 12 hours before the
event so that would be Saturday morning
on a you know of a pay-per-view you um
you be I mean yeah that morning if you
did something within the 12 hours then
that's called in competition but like
you said after the land it would still
come up on the test and if you beat me
Joey then you would get a no contest but
um technically like you said yeah you're
right it might it might be out of
competition as well it's it's all stupid
isn't it the dumbest thing that they
could have ever I'm very confused so
because I'm confused in my mind I smell
a rat like when I get confused and I
can't figure it out after I beat it up
for a couple weeks and again I'm still a
fan of sport I love Jon Jones you know I
love watching [__] Conor McGregor
fight I think he destroyed Siver but I
just you know I remember years ago
people always saying that they were
taking care of the Spanish kid what was
the Spanish kid that was supposed to be
the poster boy and then they went to
Miami and he said right they said he
wanted [__] pum money what the [__]
was he doing and they got insulted I
don't know what the story was and then
afterward when he left they said they
were cing him there were people that
said that you know the UFC even said
that they were uh you know promoting him
to be a huge star in the Spanish market
so they were giving him like kind of
easier fights is that true right or am I
[__] making this up or
something well um no no you're not
making it up and and and many fans have
felt that way not only about I'd have to
go back and and and look at I did hear
the same thing I'd have to go back and
look at the the competition he had I
remember he had some pretty tough cast
[__] yeah well let let Martinez fight
Leonard whatever the the kid who retired
was one of the best fights Garcia when
they yelled at each other in Spanish
their way yes also thought cig was
pretty tough son of a [__] at the time
so I don't know I mean yeah I'm sure the
matchmaking helped out a little bit and
I'm sure that they do do that and and a
lot of people have said the same thing
about Conor McGregor they haven't put
him up against the wrestling he's a big
name they just want to get him to the
Finish Line you know to which is the
Aldo fight so you're definitely not
crazy to thinking that Joey um but you
know some people would also say it's
smart business on the UFC's part because
those guys need to create big you know
big fights too many guys are getting
injured too many guys are are getting in
trouble so on the one hand you say wow
UFC sharp for you know creating some of
these match ups and protecting some guys
and getting themselves into some big
fights so that they could start telling
a ton of pay-per-views and and drawing
big ratings and keeping the SC going
because it's it's go through Hills and
Valleys Peaks and Valley excuse me and
right now it's going through a valley so
um
like I said some people would look at it
that way others would say no no no no no
you know that that's too much
um it's not being fair to all of your
athletes the ones that are earning the
shots you know it's supposed to be more
about putting the best versus the best
as opposed to you know shortcuts for
certain Fighters you know I love
journalism I I love reading uh the
internet the good thing about the
internet that you become fans of
different blog writers and and you write
and what I've read the two two days
things I've read and it's like right now
people are down on the UFC and I think
they're uh a couple blogs I read were
like you know all the drugs and this and
this what these [__] don't
remember is up in the 80s when [__]
the San Diego Chargers were a cocaine
fueled [__] team and I and I was
telling somebody a story Dan FS at one
time was off for three weeks first of
all him Chuck Muny that fumbling mother
[__] that [__] I must have lost
$10,000 on that [__] that was in high
school Chuck Muny he would kill me on
Monday nights because San
dieo basing [__] and nobody
really knew what was going on and then a
couple years later uh some guy wrote an
article uh he wrote a book or something
and somebody sent me like uh pieces of
it on an email and I read the excerpts
of a book and there was a story in San
Diego where they were in a hotel room
coked up to the gills the San Diego
charges and Dan FZ is walking around
with a gun and the gun slipped and it
shot him in the
arm and they called a in those days they
had a liaison with the San Diego Police
Department they called the liazon they
got a doctor to come over they stitched
them up and uh they said he slipped and
fell and he was he hurt his shoulder no
he shot himself with a 22 in the [__]
shoulder I mean this was the NFL back
then look at today an NFL got player got
caught with 200,000 in his [__] car
yeah and like 63 G and 63 Grand I mean
you know listen there's good and bad in
every sport don't be down on somebody
you know yesterday people were talking
about drugs and [__] listen uh those
guys in the NFL don't get to be 6'6 290
Pounds because they don't do something
at one point or another they that the
truth they go into broadcasting and then
right back to being you know 63
220 they're playing like 80 pounds
bigger but I'll tell you what man he
took me down memory lane because I
remember those Chargers those charger
teams John Jefferson West Chandler Air
Corel air Corel I remember those rumors
around Chuck Muny I did not know I
thought that struck me more as a choir
boy but wow no look up Chuck Muny online
tomorrow if you look up Chuck Muny
online Chuck Muny went crazy years later
I because some kids were talking Monday
I went to this meeting and they were
saying well you know Seattle I can't
believe they threw the ball and I go you
[__] are too young you
[__] don't remember a Corel
that [__] would throw a one yard
touchdown listen they could be three and
one and he would throw a 40 a 40 yard
[__] bomb that was his frame that was
why they were air Cor what was his name
Chuck Corel what was his name the the
coach I think Don Corel Don Corel so the
name of their off a Corel Dan FS had the
body of a [__] michelo bottle he was
the most unhealthiest looking
quarterback you ever seen in your
[__] life he was Square he was he all
he did was throw that's all he couldn't
move out of the pocket at all he never
got a
yard but uh yeah [__] they would have
thrown it from anywhere dog they didn't
give a [__] three and one from the
[__] boom 40 yard [__] touchdown
because they didn't give a [__] they
threw it down your throat you know long
time ago huh nobody remember that let me
tell you something their games I
remember all of that man those were some
exciting times you always had over with
them and he over were like 60 who
[__] bets an over when it's 60 and I
remember going to bed one on Monday
night the final score was
5852 like that's the type of games they
played
5448 4840 they had no
defense they had no defense their their
offense was everything their their game
strategy was listen we're just going to
bomb these [__] to death don't
worry about defense do what you guys do
just make believe you're doing what
you're
doing but you're right Dan there there
there's problems in all kinds of yeah
there's [__] problems and every
[__] he's not immune to it we're just
we're just all waking up right now
I the UFC uh you know again it's a term
I use constantly because when I see
somebody slipping in a personal view in
a business view it's uh the law
diminishing returns it happened to me
two or three times in my life I learned
my lesson and I never did it again you
could only do so much
George you can only did you guys hear
that Anderson Silva is still gonna be
allowed to Coach T uh tough four Brazil
tough Brazil 4 whatever they call it
they're filming here in Las Vegas him
and Shogun and who are the coaches and
the UFC's decided to stand by him and to
let the process play out he put out a
stat saying nope you know it was they
left the Tampa with the test team or
whatever because I've never put anything
illegal like I said earlier but they're
gonna stand by and that surprised me
honestly I thought they were
gonna they were going to replace him and
get another coach but uh that's going to
disappoint a lot of people because if
you want to if you do want to make a
statement and if you do want to project
to your fans that your athletes are
clean and you won't tolerate tolerate
anything then I would have believed that
that if they are going to let the
process play out they could have done it
without him being in a coach's
role you know when it comes to that
stuff I I I don't know what I don't want
to cut somebody's legs off because of a
mistake you know I've made tons of
mistakes I wouldn't want somebody
cutting my legs off uh if he can't fight
maybe he a good coach but I think if it
was anybody else if it was a lesser
fighter they would have they wouldn't
have had any problem because they're I
was thinking about it when you guys were
talking about all the rules the UFC is a
business and then the all the athletic
commissions like rule that just general
fighting sport so that like they're not
connected at all the NFL has its own
rules and it's it's kind of governed
within itself and it's just crazy how
like how much input they have in all the
UFC really cares about the at the end of
the day is money they don't care if
they're doing drugs they they don't they
want more exciting
fights it's like the if somebody with
the ler name was in that same position I
honestly think they would have cut them
from that
coaching when you project too much that
you that you're only going to protect
everyone at the top and you're you know
you're trying to let everybody know that
you know you treat all your athletes the
same it's fair across the board this
side whatever uh and then you do
something like this it doesn't sit well
man do you see all the other athletes
how piss they were the way the Jon Jones
situation unfolded and granted it was
kind of out of the UFC hands a little
bit because of the fact that they
couldn't penalize them you know the
commission couldn't do anything about it
so I I kind of get that but still until
the athletes kind of got all the facts
and all that I mean they were attack a
lot of them did not like it one bit and
they didn't like um but you know this
thing with Anderson Sila man it's not
done I'm sure with her more you know
they grew guys and they're going through
Growing Pains I mean I was just sitting
here going when they were just regular
they didn't have all these problems so
when they started reaching out to maau
and doing all these cards and doing you
know Fox Sports and Fox Sports One and
you don't know what you know the prelims
are on the [__] computer and and I
think that uh I think that they have a
lot on their plate and I think that
they're going to hopefully I don't know
it's just a law diminishing returns you
can't sell t-shirts and open up
different markets and you know it's just
too much and now they added women to are
fighting you know to the sport so
they're getting adjusted to that you
know that's a complete different thing
they don't know about you know what the
rules are they can't fight with a tampon
who the [__] knows you you don't [__]
know you don't [__] you don't [__]
know you know that's a [__] up next
thing know you get karate Cho in a
tampon comes out of your [__] on
national TV who the [__] knows you know
I don't know this [__] so uh but then
the rebok thing is kind of [__] up too
when you think about it that they're
they're not going to let people wear
like non-approved uniforms
and cut all that money because they're
not paying when you look at boxing
salaries or whatever the purses are like
they're millions of dollars and then the
most the people are getting like at most
a couple hundred thousand at these
fights and then you and then you're
cutting a big major way from that for
them to make money like didn't Anderson
Silva even say before this fight he
wouldn't wear it that's why maybe he
tested positive for cocaine maybe you
know who put the cocaine in the same guy
that shot John F
Kennedy cuz once he opened up his mouth
all a sudden he tested positive for uh
for [__] uh deits whatever the [__]
he tested positive for so maybe they
said oh so you don't want to [__] put
rebu on here you go we'll put a Coke
Rock we'll put a [__] steroid in your
[__] piss test and that's the end of
it all I mean who knows I don't [__]
know anymore I just uh can we go back to
something real fast go ahead brother I
want to know your guys' honest opinion
man we're shooting it straight us three
right here doing the show Church of
What's Happening Now I want to know
because I I get some heat for this I
have
just I'm in a slow process of embracing
women's mixed martial arts there's about
10 good athletes that I enjoy watching
that I thoroughly watch and go wow she
knows how to throw a head kick or a
spinning back kick or set up certain
submissions but a lot of the other young
ladies they're athletic they're tough so
I'm not g to take anything away from
them all you know all that other stuff
but I I still feel like they in the
1990s of mixed martial arts like if you
go back and see you know UFC 8 UFC 7
you're gonna see a b you know you're
gonna see some really good athletes like
Don fry Mar Coleman and then you're G
see a bunch of tomato cans out there
you're like what the [__] the sport was
really these guys and right now I uh I
just I don't know La has a CO a co- main
event and a main event it's four women
and La is one from man I'm from Southern
California Orange County I get excited
when UFC goes back there I was pissed
when they canceled the other La card and
I wasn't too happy when when Ronda
Rousey was headlining against Liz Carmo
and Leota Macha and Dan Henderson were
the coming but whatever I'm not suck I
swear to God but now La has you know um
the thing what happened with vtor and
Weidman and and I'm just not as excited
to go out to LA as I was um and I think
a lot of it honestly is just I'm just
not as down like everybody else about
wom women's next martial arts how about
you
guys I I don't really have that much of
an opinion on I've seen a few of the
fights but I was listening to AR
shaffir's podcast today and he said
something that I actually think makes
sense thinking about he said it's not
going to be exciting until someone at
least beats Ronda for like one round
they don't have to win the fight but
they actually have to like beat her for
like one or two rounds probably win the
fight but until then it just kind it's
exciting to watch her but at the same
point it's like it's not as exciting
she's like Mike Tyson you know for a
headliner you she might come out and
knock you out in [__] 30 seconds or
armar you or whatever what was wasn't
the question more about what I thought
about the women in MMA isn't that the
question yeah yeah do do you like
women's mixed martial arts as a whole
between you and
I yes I watched Misha Tate other night
against the wrestler and that wrestler
knows how to throw some [__]
punches y uh yeah and that that would be
two of the 10 that that I like I mean r
Rousey had a lot of when them two were
fighting I was into it I was I love it I
love there not many of those pairings
that come up where I go [__] yeah I
can't wait we got my 800 here's my
600 some buddies I I I just can't get
into all of them you know perfect
comparison with Mike Tyson and Ronda
Rousey that's exactly what she is she's
a terminator and you know get past a
minute or two it's it's an
accomplishment but other than that to
see a CO main event at UFC one 84 and
it's there two more ladies on top of
Ronda Rousey and C G man that doesn't
get me excited that that card needs one
more fight something has to be added
it's not gonna that's not the card vor's
got to step up somebody's got to step up
I know Gerard Massi wanted him that's a
good fight for him I heard that he
wanted to fight Mark Munoz or some [__]
I mean that you know who the [__] knows
but uh no it's time they got to add
something else to that card I I agree
with with you there but no uh am I a fan
of Ronda Rousey ah am I a fan of cateno
kind of Misha T I like the wrestler she
fought I like there's a couple girls I
don't really know their names but
they're okay to watch that they're in
the ballpark and I I know people enjoy
it and it listen man it's the [__]
future you know Hunger Games got [__]
crazy and [__] they started sharpening
their knives and throwing away the
frying pans and getting back out there
and smacking hoes like whole school and
[__] I don't know I really George you
know it it's uh it's not bad I can't lie
to you that the other night I wasn't
entertained watching me Chate against
that wrestler and looking at that
wrestler throw those punches and she's
yeah that was one of the better fights
of the C I enjoyed it too yeah she's got
kid La I'm just disappointed man I feel
like I'm going to the LI instead of UFC
card I think that what they need to do
with the women is uh do like like you
know King gano's got a kid and her
husband uh uh died my my heart goes out
to her and her family and you know these
women have stories man you know I
remember seeing I remember seeing uh
Alexander remember Godzilla the black
Alexander what was his name remember
remember what was the black kid that was
in the UFC for like five fights he came
hou Alexander Houston Alexander I saw
Houston Alexander the first time he
knocked the [__] out in 10
seconds knock his mouthpiece out came
out again Godzilla another [__]
but it wasn't until one night I was
watching something that he raised his
six kids by himself and he was a UPS
driver and he trained in the middle of
the night and had to get up in the
middle of the night and cook breakfast
and sleep only six hours and I fell in
love with the guy every time I see the
guy I give him a hug and these women
they're
moms a lot of these women have
interesting stories now those little
wiry ones that were on the ultimate
fighter those [__] are crazy them
[__] had two choices The Ultimate
Fighter or prison you could either see
that [__] on Spike or you can see that
[__] on MSNBC on a Friday night during
those prison shows you know which ones
I'm talking about those little
lightweight ones they looked a little
crazier yeah man some good ones in there
I agree yeah I'm interested to see where
this woman thing goes with this MMA goes
I'm really interesting to see this man
it's how about you Le yeah I I agree I I
like it I think it's kind the issue
they're having with having too many
fights is they have to have there's less
of a stock of women Fighters so it makes
it even more noticeable when it's a bad
fight I mean and everybody's watching
those fight listen let me tell you
something I can't wait till they have
those helmets that they put on people
and let you know what they're thinking
yeah okay if you took a UFC in Vegas on
the way you gave a helmet and you said
everybody put the helmet on during the
women fighting if there's 18,000 people
in that Arena 165 are waiting in their
mind for something to pop out they all
want a [__] costume malfunction yeah
if if if Misha Tate get somebody in a
[__] headlock and one of those tits
pop out oh my [__] god oh on Fox
television on Fox one sports oh my
[__] god that would be tremendous so
don't don't tell me every man is sitting
there at that thing going if Mesa Tate's
[__] cheek popped out of her ass
right now how good would this be
everybody's waiting for you know some of
the positions you're waiting for that
monkey to pop out of the [__] short I
mean don't don't lie to me George you
sat there and you said oh my God what if
a tit popped out right now just for a
split second that just shoots through
your mind like remember in the 70s when
you went to the movie theater during the
commercials or during the movie theater
Coca-Cola would slip commercials in
there and you'd see them subliminally
and you get thirsty for Coca-Cola same
thing they just thoughts that shoot your
mind what if a tit fell out what if know
almost happened a couple times with
Razzi yeah no everybody's waiting for
that and that's the other reason why men
love that [__] men love that listen
[__] men love that [__] to see two
women fighting jell and [__] on
Wednesday night your local bar I never
like that [__] hot [__] bikini
contest I don't give a [__] if her
monkey's out then I'm there but if she's
got a bikini on that's why I don't go to
hudas I'm going to go to hudas and eat
with [__] people with bikinis on take
that bottom off show show me that stinky
ass I want to smell that [__] rotten
Muffler when I'm eating that Wing you
know what I'm saying [__] hudas in the
stockings and [__] I love you George
thank you for calling in you're a bad
[__] you always give me great
Insight Listen to George on MMA junkie
how many times a week every day correct
yeah Monday through Friday noon Eastern
9:00 am Pacific Catch Us on SiriusXM
channel 92 and uh if not you can listen
to us on the internet ww W.M junkie.com
radio if you're ever in Vegas stop on by
and pay us a visit we're at the
manderlay day uh racing sports but
thanks guys for having me on the show
man it's always a blast I love you the
studio is
ready Studio's ready man so you guys
come on down I'll be there Memorial Day
Weekend again I'll be there Memorial Day
weekend coming a day early and co-host
Thursday and
Friday awesome all right looking forward
to it thank you I love you buddy thank
you my friend bye all right we'll see
you byebye
what the [__] Lee let me give some shout
outs to this [__] and we got to
talk about something okay very
important Allan brahan Casey Schmidt
your German [__] your little
buddy there I finally found your letter
I had it in a back pocket I took it out
that's why I don't give me [__] at shows
[__] Noah pastic Harry Henderson Brian
Nelson Jos Perez Jay dummy and ookie
spooky you sexy [__] I'll see
you next week in Austin
what's up B we got to discuss something
here with the
church I just got to shoot this duck let
me talk to you people about something I
don't want to bring you people down but
let's get this out on the table right
now we've had two call-in shows great I
[__] up because I didn't put out a
topic Lee told me today you know I love
when I go to these [__] uh comedy
shows and uh after the show we get to
talk a little bit and there's always six
or seven [__] that pull me
aside and say that me and Lee or
whatever changed their life you know my
story about prison or whatever whatever
the [__] they say it's kind of creepy
when you're after a show you
know especially when a man's looking in
the eye and saying that you helped them
out it's [__] creepy as [__] you
don't even know this [__] guy you
know but he listens to the podcast and
maybe you take something from what I
said you know whatever what you mean
creepy whatever Lee you know I pull you
aside and I go hey man I did time
whatever people talk to you and
sometimes it just seems off color I know
where they're coming from I know where
they coming from and then we do I do
emails and people go listen you inspire
me to do this or whatever and I
appreciate it and then when we do the
call-in show people call up and they're
like hey man we really dig what you did
blah blah blah blah you know whatever
when my father was dying you were there
something about your funeral here we go
[__] uh the Fast and the Furious I
got the Chinese against the [__]
poock uh I'm going to tell you something
guys that's all great in D there we help
you out or maybe a story or I I help you
relate I just want you guys to know that
you guys help me out I have a notebook
that I have and when I get back from the
road it's just a special notebook that I
open up and it'll say uh
22 to
28 you know and that's the week Monday
through the following Sunday and I write
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and I
write what I have to do on Monday I do a
podcast on Wednesday I do a podcast
Monday I go to Jiu-Jitsu Wednesday I go
to Jiu-Jitsu Thursday I take a flight
you know 1:45 on Tuesday I got Doctor
Amy and then as the schedule comes in I
ride around it so when people call me so
when I wake up on two Monday I know
exactly what I have to do but then I
have side things like I have to call
Kyle to write my shirt so I'll write
Kyle I have to go get blood out take
blood out for this knee I'll go right
Blood on the corner I'll put my goal for
the week to work out
two weights or I'll put two bikes and
two Jiu-Jitsu and then I'll put Jackie
and that's my daughter's name and I've
been doing this for about a year every
week that's my other daughter the 25y
old and every uh every week that's how I
start my week and by the time I leave on
Thursday I always check off all the [__]
that I'm supposed to do like today it
said Doctor 10:00 11:00 a.m. Jiu-Jitsu I
said David Foley was supposed to meet
our friend David Foley from whatever I
erased it then at 800m podcast that's my
day but some part of the day sometimes
I'll write I have to call somebody in
there but my goal for the week was
always to call my daughter it's been and
I'm not lying to you guys and I told my
wife and I showed her a notebook I go
look at this every
[__] uh
goal this week for the last year has
been to call my daughter every week I
say that to myself I got to call my
daughter I got to call my daughter call
my daughter
well this week uh yesterday she turned
25 years old and I wasn't even thinking
about my friend lubs called me on Monday
he goes tell your daughter I said Happy
Birthday and because it's L's birthday
also on the 3D of February so he was
born the same day as my
daughter's so uh we did the call-in show
Monday night and it was on my mind
Monday I thought about calling her you
know I've been thinking about it I
thought about picking up the phone in a
couple hotels cuz they wouldn't see the
incoming call calling in and they would
pick it up and then I would go hi this
is Joey Diaz and I talk to Jackie I
would catch him off
guard so yesterday I woke up and I had
to go to the I had to do something in
the morning and then I had to go to
daycare with my wife and Terry to look
at daycares and we walk through the
daycare and the Midway there Terry goes
what's going on I can see the smoke
coming out of your ears not insane go no
no I'm just thinking about I got to put
Mercy in the [__] daycare you know uh
she's growing you know but what I was
and then I went to the daycare when I
went to the daycare Jackie I used to
walk her the daycare when I had her I
used to be a roofing estimator my wife
used to cut hair so the daycare was up
the corner so while I was at that
daycare I started thinking about my
daughter oh my God last time I was in
the daycare was I would pick Jackie up
and then once she had a kid that bitter
so I told her to bite the kid back and
they let then let me come back to the
dayare so uh I left there yesterday and
uh my goal was to go home eat lunch and
call Jackie and then I got high and I
didn't call her and I took a nap instead
and and I woke up and I sat up at the
computer and I go you know what I got to
get the [__] out of here I took a shower
I got dressed I went to the weed store
and I went to Marie
Etc I bought a [__] sugar-free coffee
I sat down I opened up my
notebook and to top it off I the chapter
that I'm writing right now I'm trying to
write for this book is about me walking
away what really happened uh you know I
was going to war with them but the only
thing that was keeping me alive was
comedy I it was the first time in my
life I was making strides doing
comedy and then I realized the truth
that's why I told you
[__] the truth of the matter
was that they yanked this little girl
from me they yanked her from me with the
with the cost of attorneys like I was
looking at it and how I was I would only
get her on Wednesdays from 2: to 7 and
every other Sunday from 2: to
7 and basically they yanked it from me
but they yanked it from me in a legal
way and the beauty of it was they
laughed in my face and when I always
talk about the kiss of death and Karma
and things coming back well let me tell
you
something it was the way when I when we
giggle here how I rob somebody and I
giggle about it it was done to me you
know it was done to me this is why I
know all about Karma I know all about
kisses of death and this is one of those
stories that uh they yanked me they
[__] me up the ass you know when
somebody [__] you up the ass and they
steal something from you and you see
them every day you ever get into a fist
fight with somebody and they break your
nose and you guys shaked hands but you
never really remembered you never really
forgot that [__] broken nose like
you're like one of these nights we're
going to get drunk and I'm gonna break
his [__] head for him breaking my
nose it's one of those things like I
never really forgot the pain I never
really forgot what I went through like
the embarrassment of somebody taking
something from me yeah I could tell you
guys that uh you
know I wanted uh her to grow up better
whatever the truth doesn't matter was
that they were going to yanker for me
and I was going to lose my mind and
[__] stab somebody so I said [__] it
let me go do comedy
and but if I go do comedy and I commit
to this I got to do something in my life
to make it worth my while and that's the
only way I could come back and I always
wanted to kill those people my revenge
was to just do better just to stay alive
and I'm here today so yesterday I was at
the coffee shop I took a couple sips of
that coffee and I called
no way yep did you pick up nope I got a
machine I said this is Joey Diaz it's
Jackie's birthday today it's the 25th
birthday I want you guys to tell her I
said happy birthday and I love it and uh
you know I don't know what happened the
years got biased and I just want to make
that call to see if we can make this
happen this is my number 323 I told my
number and I said if she doesn't want to
call that's fine too I just know in my
heart that I made this this [__] call
and I hung up the phone I tell you what
I lost 80 [__] pounds in my heart I'm
not going to lie to you Le it was
amazing I went to that Laugh Factory
last night and I tore that room in half
and then I went to the store and tore
that [__] room in half and I went to
Jiu-Jitsu and my life has changed
dramatically and I and I don't and it's
not something I did it's something that
you guys did you know why because you
guys keep me in check because if I'm
gonna talk the [__] I talk I got to
[__] back it up so in my life right
now I took care of all my loose ends and
it's because of the church so we're even
[__] don't ever come up to me
again after a show and tell me that I
help you get your life together or that
me and Lee got you off track because
we're even I would have never done this
on my own but I knew that I had to do
this for you guys in mind I [__] call
and you know what they didn't call back
and guess what I don't give a [__] guys
I went ahead I
called they probably sitting around
scratching their [__] heads going
what the [__] is our next move you know
what their next move is to just move on
with their life to do what they think is
best for them do you think she even
heard the
message Le I don't know I don't know and
I I don't care it's like I got it out I
did I made my move you know what I'm
saying I think that a lot of things are
going to change in my life just because
of me uh making that call for a long
time I was very scared how long did it
take you to do it like how long had it
been I've been trying for a year
probably 18 months to make a
call and the deeper I got in with you
guys I knew how to make that call so I
just started by writing her name on the
side of the page and looking at it on my
schedule every day so every day when I
look up my schedule I see Tuesday I have
to go to acup punch I got to drive Terry
here I got to meet with this guy from
Disney and in the corner I would see
what X's have been up and it would
always be Jackie and every week there's
two things I still haven't gone for the
blood test either I'm not going to lie
to you guys I'll probably do that next
week now that I got this out of probably
you know what I'm saying cuz [__] that
blood test of [__] [__] feeling
good tonight it's a beautiful Wednesday
night to be alive man uh I took a big
weight off my chest on my shoulders when
I made that call how stressful was it
when you like the phone was working was
your heart racing it was [__] horrid
it really was hor I don't like those
people guys I don't like those people at
all I don't like getting uh I learned a
big lesson with them I learned how I
felt when I robbed people they robbed me
they took something big from me and I'm
going tell you something when I die and
I go to heaven on purgatory and I see my
mother she's going to give me a kiss and
she going to give me a hug and she look
at me she goes I can't believe you let
those [__] [__] live cuz I
know the blood we have in this the
Valdez blood that's like like when I
even think about it Lee I want to get on
a plane and parachute out where they
live and just blow up the [__] house
but I can't I have responsibilities to
you guys I have responsibility to my
wife I have responsibility to my
daughter but in my heart because they
really really really did get over on me
they really got over on me Le and you
don't know what the pain and it's not
somebody a random person it's somebody
you had a relationship with at one time
it's somebody that you shared stuff with
it's somebody that you know it was a
bond all right we broke up we don't get
along boom boom boom that's it it's over
they kicked me when I was down and then
they even took my dog who takes your
[__] dog they took my dog that's
[__] up and would give me back to the
[__] dog like they were they were
like antagonizing me so part of me to
this day feels like a [__] [__] [__]
for not [__] them up but I wouldn't
have done anybody good in jail I didn't
belong in [__] jail so uh I just want
to thank you guys for keeping me in
check and making me think at least in
that direction that I had to do this and
I went to the church I ain't going to LY
you I wouldn't have done it on my own
I'm a [__] [__] that's
awesome that's really cool that you got
I mean it's uh did it happen because it
was her birthday or were you just ready
it was because it was the 25th birthday
yeah it was a 25th for birthday what the
[__] you know we probably haven't spoken
for [__] 10 years what the [__] Lee
it's uh it's that time and I've got a
thousand emails from people from the
church s me to contactor and they knew
they knew I always knew they were
correct I never felt out of line I
always knew that they were correct and
what their words were there were a
couple people that were [__] about
it you
know but uh I did it and that's it
that's what the church is all about you
know what man you take baby steps
whatever it takes you but you always
work to that [__] goal and that's all
I ever [__] do man just working
towards that goal a little bit you know
what I'm saying what do you got planned
this weekend [__] ho I feel you dog um
what are you doing what are you doing
Friday night we don't have any plans yet
you keep it Loose this weekend no
[__] Chinese restaurants and Hong
Kong Village you know what's wrong with
Hong Kong Village nothing I'm just
saying you know you always got an exotic
what about satday that way you take it
we don't have any plans yet we're going
to figure some stuff out you guys so you
guys are like an in couple you Uber
you taking Uber every once in a while
yeah it's cheap it's cheap as [__] so
what are you going to do the rest of the
night you little I don't have a spot the
store oh my God I got the college s this
one and a half star thing is not not for
not good for talking yes it is you look
beautiful you just uptight I don't know
what the [__] you're uptight I'm trying
to take the stick out of your ass it's a
beautiful night to be alive you know
what I'm saying you got to stay loose
you got your blue shirt on your hair
looks nice look at you what the [__] you
go home and you're Panic I've been
trying to tell this guy I'm not
panicking that he has anxiety but when
he takes the edible then he realizes why
he goes home no I have anxiety when you
come into the office and you always come
in you like Cramer when you come in it's
always a different entrance and then you
have this like little
backpack and you just go you have like
it's like a a a gift backpack from a
show it has like 34 Pockets with you cuz
you keep going but different tubes you
pop the tube you pull different bags oh
please and then just I just see all
you're like you're just pulling them
like you laugh you just look up and
smile it's like the creepiest thing I
got everything on this [__] bed I
know and there's like 18 18 zippers and
I got everything glasses backup glasses
lighters backup lighters rolling papers
I think I got a syringe like Rambo I got
[__] nose
spray I got everything in there I got
[__] I don't have no food in there I
should get some tra mix just in case
[__] goes bad I'm always prepared I got
a few
carbohydrates I don't know what the [__]
they are I don't know I don't know what
to think about steroids in
sports I guess it it it's cheating but
at some like could could they just let
people do whatever they wanted and
because it seems like they're doing it
anyways or I don't know how I feel as a
fan listen I heard a rumor this what I
heard I heard that [__] steroid save
baseball at that time I wasn't watching
baseball like Sammy Sosa Maguire yeah I
knew that they were having that baseball
race whatever the [__] they were doing
but I wasn't involved with it so I
didn't really wasn't paying
attention you know in football what do
you want to see you want to see hits you
want to see people blasting each other
now you can't do the helmet to helmets
no more they have a lot of restrictions
and whatnot but
still I mean I don't know it's like a
hypocritical type thing it's like a uh a
uh I'll do but don't you know what I'm
saying like especially with the NFL cuz
they sell pictures of the hits and they
used to have like DVDs of the best hits
and now all of a sudden they care it's
it's like same thing we were talking
about with the UFC where it's just all
about money they don't they they seem
they say they care but they really
probably don't nobody cares Le you ever
see CH Bomar in Bronx toown no that's
you never saw that movie either
no oh my my God is that a good movie
yeah it's a pretty good [__] movie
but you know it's a good [__] movie I
haven't seen yet I haven't seen it one
you know what's a funny ass movie
Bullets Over Broadway see if they got
something up on Bullets Over [__]
Broadway Le while we looking it up let
me give a shout out to my sponsors here
on it always [__] rocking it with the
shroom Tech I took some Alpha brains
today I went down to [__] uh to
Jiu-Jitsu down there with hean Machado I
also blasted a little shroom Tech sport
I did well today you know I breathed
heavy I had to get up and [__] go
outside and breathe but I still lasted a
couple [__] sparing sessions also a
shout out to Iron Dragon TV I love them
the best thing about these guys is list
like on it on it is simple you go to on
it.com you look around you see what they
got I can't get you 10% off on the
weights and the ropes and nothing like
that but I get you 10% off on the
minerals and vitamins all right so you
go to h.com go try it with the alpha
bring get the smallest size boom 10% off
gets delivered right to your [__]
house go on the cycle of it I guarantee
you love it if not you get your money
back guarantee but to do that you got to
go to the on box and press in church oh
[__] c h you R CH H and get 10% off you
also have to stay on a program you can't
[__] lose with this thing I'm telling
you right now look at me I'm feeling
good my mind is clicking that's because
of the Alpha Brain I went back on it
what I [__] you know no
[__] I love you [__] suckers
again right here my main man day f
Iron Dragon TV [__] around the house
classic martial arts classic martial
arts you understand me the itman series
what else Jackie Chan early Jackie Chan
when he was working for [__] nonunion
with Puerto Ricans with Sans and Scott's
tape on their eyes this is deep and [__]
we ain't [__] around no more all
those type of film genres if you like
classic Marshal art films if you like
martial arts films at all go to
irondragon tv.com they're going to rock
your [__] world you're going to love
what they have well I dog go to
irondragon tv.com they got a box press
in Joey oh [__] get two free movies
these people don't [__] around this is
nanch they're the same people who
sponsored Tim Kennedy and another UFC
fight I love Dave Foy I'm G to meet him
tomorrow I'm telling you go to Iron
Dragon TV if you like classic martial
art films tell a friend give him the
[__] what they put in the Box Joey
boom there you go and they get two free
movies to get the party started
you're sitting there with those same
Rotty [__] underwears rotting up
giving you that mold under your nut sack
you got to scratch you you can't even
scratch a second time you got to go to
the bathroom in front of your mother why
you doing that to yourself do yourself a
favor go to meundies.com today they got
a tremendous selection of shorts those
little tight box of shorts why you
wearing those [__] white cotton
shorts with skid marks in them Meyes has
tremendous underwear men and women's
thongs tremendous the cotton is
something that you've never had I have
my [__] pair on right now they're
floating on my nut sack something that
you've never won before you understand
me it takes the Heat and the sweat away
from your nut sack if you wear me on
this I wear me on this to Jiu-Jitsu all
the [__] time you know why Comfort
you're nut sack don't POA it's a
tremendous feeling why why am I telling
you listen go to me.com look at what
they have start with one pair I ain't
[__] around start with one pair go to
the box and press in Joey and you get
20% send off your first order plus right
yeah plus free delivery free shipping to
us and Canada go to meundies.com right
now look at the selection you going to
love it Valentine's Day is coming stop
being a [__] get her a nice
tongue then you got no [__]
excuses you know the best thing about
the thong you slide that [__]
out and shove your tongue in that little
monkey and sniff that little
Bush it's all over it's better with me
on the you understand me CU it keeps the
heat in there the churches warm like a
cookie when you check it to a hotel you
know what I'm saying check to a hotel
and give you that warm cookie that's
what it is with the meundies and you get
that little monkey it's shave [__]
tremendous anyway go to me.com right now
and put him what in the Box Joey Joey
and get 20% off your first order and
they ship to Canada United States
comfortable as [__] listen why are you
eating those potato chips why you eating
those [__] chips and all that [__]
those labamba peanuts with the [__]
mint on them that [__] end today you
know why because I'm gonna turn you into
something that's [__] free free as
[__]
cancer
naturebox.com nobody's better than
NatureBox nutritious healthy diet
dietitian approved meals sent right to
your door and you know what's going to
cost you the first time Grace free ugats
nothing you know why because they know
for a fact they're gonna hook you on
something that's how good the [__]
who gives you anything for free nobody
somebody gives you something for free
next thing know you're sucking their
dick in an Alleyway not with [__]
naturebox.com they're gonna send you
five bags direct to your house three
small bags two big bags the Coca almonds
the cinnamon the French toast uh sticks
sticks sticks the the colonel qus sticks
he looks like James getting the feeling
his last movie The Drop with the [__]
beard and [__] they got those little
popcorns the The Cinnamon French toast
the cocoa almonds delicious the
plantains the Philippine whatever the
sweet plantains are delicious listen
don't don't listen to me go to [__]
naturebox.com see what they got you are
going to [__] flip all right they're
going to ship it to you for free Grace
go to the Box on nature box and press in
Joey and get your free free ug gots
nothing Nature Box sample four small
bags one big bag I'm telling you you're
going to change your [__] life and
you can tell them what to send you
that's how good they are please again on
it l dragon V meundies.com and
naturebox.com support them they support
us give them their love what do you got
for [__] Bullets Over Broadway what
scene you got it's all it's only pulling
up plays no movie no film Bullets Over
Broadway the movie okay you all this is
what I got to deal with
people breaking my hly okay here we go
here's something what's the SC it says
highlights hold yeah let's see what they
have I forgot how good this movie was
there's an ad hold
on how come this ain't queued up
[Music]
cuz fluid it's because it's lighter
fluid what what is this tonight's show
forget it you're [__] slipping anyway
it's a movie about a dude that has a
play and he needs an investor so the mob
invest in the play and it's uh Chaz pom
Terry early on [__]
hilarious so he invests money in it but
he has to rewrite it with the guy and he
turns out to be a great
writer so he gives Direction and stuff
when the guy don't listen he shoots him
he shoots the [__] [__] tremendous I
laugh Jenifer til's in it the dude who
was in uh the movie with Shawn pen the
state of grace that played the mobster
Jimmy the one that was in analyzed that
and analyzed this the fat guy jelly he's
in it it's a great [__] moovie if you
get a chance Bullets Over Broadway
that's how we roll [__] so that's
it that's all I got for you
[__] on a Wednesday night
what's up Lee what's up you're stoned
had a nice week right nobody bothered
nobody next week I'm in Cap City so you
don't want to go to Cap City I would
have gone what are you going to do you
going to sit with Mama for Valentine's
Day what are you taking it I told we're
doing the whole the foods you like
that's right you think ridiculous the
foods you like that's right what are the
foods you like in- and out Buffalo Wild
Wings and P what are you going get in
that burger let the people know what are
you going to get huh oh what am I going
to get yeah just a double double one
double double no fries I'll share her
fries those fries stink how many
calories it doubled up I don't know
probably 5 or 600 no you don't think so
no a double double is a lot more than 5
how much is a single I thought you said
the single was like 400 or something
yeah so double doubles two patties [__]
on another piece of bread so where do
you get that's going to that's a killer
with the with the [__] double double
sauce on it that's 1,000 calories my
friend you know yeah probably you'll be
on the epileptical for three days just
sweating up a storm that's what I did
today did you really so you did an hour
15 yeah look at you you ding to nothing
give me the crap give the people on TV
the crap look at you give the bicep pose
the double open oh [__] [__] look at you
you sexy [__] all
right as long as you're happy brother
that's all I want I'm happy I don't know
how you get this High you call me and
you torture me throughout the day I've
been high all [__] day listen as soon
as I get done with my business I I go
stop by the weed stor what do you mean
get done with your business you're doing
this at 6:00 a.m. no I smoke dope as I'm
doing my business but as soon as I'm
done with my business I pop the edible
of life and after the party starts in my
day nothing wrong with that I'm just
adding some color to my [__] life
guys like I'm not a fighter I don't need
to fight nobody I can get high I can get
high Lee don't [__] with me [__] let's
end this [__] I love you guys
another shout out to an IT Iron Dragon
TV
meundies and
naturebox.com Cap City next
[__] week two weeks after that
Indianapolis crackers and
[__] crackers and [__] look at you Lee
read this [__] thing well you sitting
there like a Bo now that the show's over
don't forget to go to naturebox.com and
the show's been over all
right I don't know why you're giving me
the business I'm not giving nobody no B
you know I love you I love when Steve
says go to naturebox.com and sign up to
get your free sampler box of great
tasting healthy snacks forget the
vending machine and start snacking
Smarter with delic delicious treats like
barbecue Kettle Colonels go to
naturebox.com Joey that's naturebox.com
Joey go to meundies.com joeey and get
20% off of your first order of men's and
women's underwear there and right now
they're going to give you free shipping
in the US and Canada go to irondragon
tv.com and new sco Joey to get two free
rentals of all of their great martial
arts movies and go to on it.com and use
cold Church to get 10% off of all their
optimization
[Applause]
products
t